[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this week i'm trying something kind of
different
apple sent me the new iphone 13 pro to
review and i've been roaming around the
north cascades in washington seeing what
this phone can do some of you have asked
about my camera setup and while i do use
my canon r5 and lenses for most
landscape scenes at least half of what
you see here on my youtube channel is
shot with my iphone
so thought it would be fun to film a
review of this phone out here on the
road and share my overall thoughts from
a photographer's perspective
this isn't a deep dive on technical
specs mostly i just want to show you
what this phone can do from a visual
standpoint
like they say the best camera is the one
you have with you
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
do
[Music]
i'm driving on the north cascades
highway right now and the fall colors
are so beautiful
it's pretty rainy out but um
yeah so i'm getting this shot by holding
out my right hand
holding the iphone
and
it's pretty stable i think i guess we'll
find out but
yeah this is a front-facing camera so
quality seems pretty good
and i have no idea how the audio will
sound but
especially with the road noise and the
rain
but i guess we'll find out together
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
wow this is so cool do you know what
kind of salmon these are
so these are salmon
and they're coming up stream to spawn
and they've lived their whole lives out
at sea
how cool is that
so
look outside
[Music]
painted skies here comes the light
it's in your eyes
[Music]
fear
[Music]
this
[Music]
oh this view is incredible
so
this is cinematic mode and you can see
it's blurring the background here
the way a prime lens would blur the
background
which is pretty incredible for an iphone
it's uh
pretty awesome to be able to
just take a phone up into the mountains
and get this kind of quality video
but check out this view
[Music]
is
everything
[Music]
made it up to the top
this view
is ridiculous
oh that was super crooked
um and this is cinematic mode so you can
see there's a little bit of blur in the
background here which is nice and yeah
it was a little bit of a slog up that
last bit but now it's getting chilly so
put on all the layers
and
yeah overall this phone is pretty
spectacular there's a few different
talking points i want to go over stuff
that you know i've been using it for
about two weeks now and stuff i want to
mention that i can't remember up here on
the mountain top plus it's about to get
dark soon so we should probably hike
down because we got four three and a
half or four miles we're not sure to get
back down to
the vehicles gonna have to get a move on
but i will talk to you about the phone
when i'm back at the van all right so
it's 7 30
and it's already
basically
pretty much night time
and you can also use your iphone
as headlamp
photography slash hiking multi-tool
we are back in the van and i am filming
this on the iphone 13 pro okay so i've
had this phone for about two weeks now
and there are a couple of things that
have really stood out to me first is the
battery life i've noticed that i'm
reaching for my cord way less often than
i have in the past and in some instances
i've even gone a whole day without
having to charge my phone at all so
being on the road or if you live a
mobile lifestyle or any lifestyle really
just not having to charge your phone as
often is amazing it's definitely a nice
upgrade second the one terabyte storage
option is a game changer that's what
this phone is and i was able to film
this entire vlog without having to stop
and offload or delete files or anything
like that which really allowed me to
stay in the creative mindset throughout
the entire filming process
and what's also nice is you can go
through and review each individual clip
you can scrub through you can trim you
can delete before you drop those files
over into your editing timeline and the
fact that you can do that natively on
the phone while filming i could just see
how this would save me so much time in
the editing process moving forward also
stabilization is better low light
capture is better these cameras actually
have a wider aperture than the iphone
pro 12 which means less noise overall um
that clip that i just showed you where i
was walking through the dark without a
headlamp but filming it you could see
how dark it was and when i took this
photo this was taken three seconds hand
held no tripod
and you can still see some light in
there which is remarkable for a mobile
device with the pro the cinematic macro
and 77 millimeter modes have been really
fun to experiment with it uses digital
blur so there are some instances where
you can you know see that it's not
perfect if you zoom in but it's still
really incredible technology and it's a
small price to pay when you consider how
much you would have to spend and invest
into a camera and the lenses and all of
the things and also how heavy that stuff
is like when i lug my camera and lenses
up onto a mountain top
oh i mean in some sometimes it gets as
heavy as 12 pounds the iphone obviously
weighs a fraction of that and it costs
less and it's multifunctional you know
you use your phone for so many things
and it just so happens to be an
excellent vlogging camera that being
said if you already have the iphone 11
or 12 or any of the pro models you
already have an incredible device in
your pocket i use the iphone 12 pro for
the past year i absolutely loved it in
fact i use it to film at least 50 of
what you've seen on this channel like i
said earlier so
there's no need to upgrade but if you
are looking for something that really
kicks it up a notch and they can kind of
take your content to the next level
without investing in all of that camera
gear this is it let me know if you guys
like this video and if you'd like to see
more gear based reviews in the future i
had a lot of fun filming this one with
nathaniel wise who is also an outdoor
adventure photographer if you aren't
following him already definitely go
check out his channel also i'm leaving
for europe in a couple days i'm super
excited i'll be over there for about
three weeks with some friends and i'll
be going to italy and switzerland for
sure and potentially france and austria
not totally sure yet but if you'd like
to see some mountain content
fall colors
um really good food and just general
whatever we get up to in europe
subscribe
and if not don't worry about it
um and also like and comment this video
if you want to but either way i
appreciate you being here thank you and
i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
should you get me coming out of the
toilet